[Music]
laravel a full stack PHP based web
framework famous for its carefully
crafted and much-loved developer
experience it was created in 2011 by
Taylor otwell who was inspired by prior
work like codeigniter or Symphony and
rails it has a large following of
independent developers thanks to its
laser focus on clean and minimal code
along with a huge ecosystem of tools
that can do the heavy lifting
traditionally it's used as a model view
controller framework to build
server-side web applications a model
represents data that can live in a wide
variety of databases while a view
represents what the end user sees in
HTML the user powered by blade templates
that can buy a PHP and HTML code into a
single file and finally we have a router
and controllers in the middle which
allow the user to safely interact with
the data model this pattern can be used
to build monolithic applications but
laravel can also build Standalone apis
or integrate with popular front-end
Frameworks thanks to an adjacent Library
called inertia most importantly though
its ecosystem has out-of-the-box
solutions for features like user
authentication payments full text search
and many other others to get started
install PHP and composer then create a
new project by default it will be
configured with mySQL as the database
the application lifecycle starts in the
index PHP file when a user makes a
request it goes to the HTTP kernel which
contains middleware to intercept the
request and register service providers
like a router which itself determines
that controller action to trigger based
on the URL the user navigated to now a
controller is just a PHP class that
contains a variety of methods like show
update edit and destroy it follows a
convention where show represents a git
request for an individual entity while
store represents a post request to
create a new entity inside a method we
might use a model to make a query to the
database but instead of raw SQL code it
uses eloquent orm making the code far
more human readable every database table
has a corresponding model class which
can be customized as needed now back in
the controller the return value from a
method is a view the view is a blade
template that interpolates the data from
the database directly into HTML ml it
has the full power of PHP allowing you
to implement conditional logic and loops
with a familiar syntax but laravel comes
with a ton of other built-in features
like cues file storage websockets for
real-time apps just to name a few this
has been laravel in 100 seconds hit the
like button if you want to see more
short videos like this thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one